[Music]
this is some really cool uh spy news an
fda executive officer was caught on a
hidden camera
saying that biden will force an annual
coveted shot that would be recurring
fountain of revenue for drug firms
shut the [ __ ] up goodness wow wow wow
wow a spy for project variances
uh
disguise herself as like basically uh
was dating the exec
and got on camera all this stuff just
listen to it what the [ __ ] dude like
this is what i've been saying and people
have been calling us conspiracy theories
so this guy yeah but this guy is
actually he's an fda executive officer
for like 20 plus years this is not just
some random yeah so just listen to what
he says and then i'll continue with
everything else that's stemming from
this but like check this out if i didn't
want to and i played as many people as
possible so you don't have to get an
angle
why did the angle
[Music]
that's a clear hidden camera though huh
products if they can get
every person required an annual vaccine
that is a recurring return of
money this is crazy dude this is nuts
just from everything i've heard they're
not calling them out of rivers meet
christopher
dude okay so so here's the thing right
like this is what pisses me the [ __ ] off
is a lot of people always question the
integrity of why are why are the
government going so [ __ ] far to force
people to get vaccinated if the science
already says that the vaccinations don't
really [ __ ] do [ __ ] where in the very
beginning they're like okay if you're
vaccinated you can't get other people
sick you're immune to it whatever right
and then on top of that it's at this
point where okay
what's really going on and then they're
calling you a [ __ ] fringe anti-vaxxer
especially what they're doing to the
truckers in canada i was like what the
[ __ ] but here here's the thing and i'm
going to explain this to you
the vaccines
only work if people get them 100 yeah
that's the issue right so when you say
hey you're gonna get vaccinated it's not
a cure
obviously no no but that knew what we're
saying but even the way you just said it
yeah i'm gonna get vaccinated i'm gonna
still get covered yeah of course no no
yeah i know that so but like a lot of
people don't operate that way but then
the news literally said if you get the
vaccine you can't get sick that's a
disadvantage i agree with that [ __ ] that
up
right so that's either they're not doing
their homework they're either lying
right or they're [ __ ] stupid right
because i knew that if i get the flu
shot i could still get the flu everyone
that understands viruses vaccines if you
get how it works but the [ __ ] news
lied and this is why i was like wait a
minute why are they saying this and then
i was like it's probably money motivated
but of course like everything else in
this country but but also too there was
a they had i forgot this guy's name but
he was a researcher and he's like
he's he's in the vaccine field and he
was working with with pfizer and all
these companies but he's kind of an
independent party and he's a researcher
so he was on lex friedman's podcast and
he was talking about how um in the
beginning they all thought in the
scientific community that the vaccine
would be able to stop you from getting
covered completely completely that's
what they as a the scientific community
that was developing it they thought that
was the thing and then later they found
out with more testing that it wasn't the
case right so that's i think that is
yeah that could be an issue like it's a
combination of having the news cycle
social media yeah and people just
commenting every 10 minutes whereas like
back in the day they would have spent
years and not none of us would know any
of this information right now any dumb
[ __ ] can go on the internet and be like
and their opinion is equated the same
and the same
level of legitimacy i've gone into
arguments with friends who are like i'm
not getting the vaccine i'm like that's
cool dude but then you're gonna have to
eat [ __ ] when things happen and i'm like
also where are you getting information
from and they send me like a [ __ ]
live journal exactly
and i'm like see this is why you're an
idiot you're an idiot not because you
don't want to get the vaccinius because
you literally can't tell the difference
between a medical journal and a [ __ ]
like marble notebook
and anybody could have a [ __ ]
wordpress site
even if you gave them a study though
this is the other half of it too it's
like how many like i'm too stupid to
understand like what's on a [ __ ]
study so like you could even read a
scientific journal and then not
understand exactly so that's what
but then like instead of asking your
parents
ask your doctor yeah like instead of
asking
your best friend instead of me being
like yo nick what do you think of the
cove let me tell you i heard on this
podcast can you tell me how mrna
oh yeah for sure
i feel like the people that i'm talking
to about this they're like i read a
study and like did you read it did you
yeah all you have to say is what study
and if they can't tell you the study
most of the time they can't or if they
do then i look at it and it's like this
isn't a study this is like a like a not
even a full like summary of the study
this is like a headline about us
vaccination obviously helps with death
vaccination helps with mitigating spread
and if you're
not obese or over the age of 60 or have
like an illness that makes you high risk
chances are you're gonna be okay dude
statistically but here's the thing this
is the moral issue
are you okay with not being vaccinated
and being the jackass who kills
everyone's grandmother
that's really what the question is like
do i think you're going to get covenant
and die no
dude what does the math say you will
survive but what does the math say you
could get covent and then kill
grandma kill streak the map on that is
high but if you have the vaccine and if
you could still get covet then you could
still get grandma's killed no but the
the the viral count so see this is where
science comes to play the viral count of
someone who is vaccinated versus
unvaccinated or completely different so
with the viral account they're less
contagious correct and they show up like
more people are getting vaccinated right
yeah then they're also showing more
people are getting infected but there's
way less deaths because of the fact that
more people well actually there's way
more deaths with omnicron than there is
delta really because
it just spreads so much
it spreads so much is that world wider
than the us and you i believe in the us
but omnicron is less deadly
than delta but there's more people
getting it but more people are getting
it more maybe
it's like different because the pool of
people who are exposed to omnicron is
way higher they're like oh yeah there's
more debts but if you take the ratio of
people dying from army crime versus
delta the percentage for delta is so
it's more deadly you know so like you
see it goes back to the media so what is
the media gonna do how do we get our
money more people are dying off
everyone runs like they have this story
they had this guy named john abrams and
he's like a he is a another medical
researcher guy uh and he he's writing
books against like big pharma and he was
talking about like he's like dude this
vaccine is a very good vaccine it's it's
like it's pretty solid but he says where
it gets fishy with pfizer and where we
kind of
think oh these guys are [ __ ]
conspiracy they're like yeah they're up
to some [ __ ] is
they are going to
dominate the sales in the first world
they're going to sell their vaccine to
the people that will have the money to
buy it but these other countries like
the third world countries are not
they're getting like maybe a quarter of
these vaccines and they're the people
that need it the most but because of
they're not getting these vaccines
they're more likely to have new variants
and that will go back to the us like
this will spread and it will create more
of an issue so if we're not getting the
vaccine worldwide aren't the third world
countries not dropping like flies and
they don't even have i have no idea
there's a quick answer that no one wants
to talk about it's because half our
country's obese that's a big yeah yeah
for sure for sure and no one wants to
really
yeah
no one wants to talk about preventative
medicine which like obviously like you
know we all know this
coming from you know fitness and stuff
like the best way to not get sick is
just to be healthy is to be healthy like
for example if you eat well
exercise regularly
but then never sleep yeah or you're
gonna get sick right so it's like you
have to do the combination
of all of it if you leave one if you if
you exercise and sleep well and you have
good hygiene but then eat mcdonald's
every day like you're going to be a pig
but mcdonald's is wonderful you know the
comment dude i told you 40 chicken
nuggets put it in front of me right now
commonality of all the deaths of kovid
was a vitamin d deficiency which means
that they weren't getting sun they
weren't i don't have i have a vitamin d
deficiency oh really you better get some
sun bro i know it's really strange right
you know what
so all this stuff makes sense right what
do you think but i hate it
but the crazy thing right now that we're
all witnessing are the hit pieces
against people who might just be maybe
criticizing
you know certain companies that are
related to covet or maybe the mandates
or whatever and this the the outright
smearing of people that are legitimate
you know virologists or doctors or
whatever that [ __ ] blows my mind such as
robert malone when he was on joe rogan
this whole thing about joe rogan
spreading misinformation of covet i
looked into that and really
robert malone was one of the uh
virologists that invented mrna
technology he actually got cancelled
before joe rogan and uh that's why joe
rogan wanted to have him on to talk
about it why did he get canceled before
that i have no idea a lot of people
getting he's on the fringe he was
getting science scientifically so i
think that's why joe rogan wanted to
bring him on he's like this guy needs a
megaphone he he sometimes he apparently
the criticism that robert malone got for
that podcast is that he's making these
claims that aren't necessarily
a hundred percent backed by the
scientific community and as far as the
consensus of like
but you could say that but also you
can't jump to that but it's not
peer-reviewed right but he also invented
the mrna and he has more patents than
anyone else in that in that yeah but
then you still have to get a bunch of
people to review that like you can't
just be yeah like if one doctor says
that's cool but then a thousand doctors
have to say we agree with you yeah and
then then you say okay this works right
but i also think that's why the open
discussion is important rather than just
you shut up i shut up yeah i i totally i
totally agree with you but that also
makes it way more fishy right when they
block a voice from this guy because in
reality it's like okay
other news companies that are are way
better like like say like breaking
points they're a really good news
company they said okay we see that
robert malone said these claims so we're
going to bring other experts in the
field so to point by point
deduce and figure out why what he said
was
how we could add more context and have a
clear picture to these claims that he's
saying so but he's also like it's not
that he's completely wrong it's just
there were a couple of things where he
needed to clarify a little bit better i
i think it's just like you know with
sort of the cancellation stuff it comes
down to social responsibility right in
the sense of you can bring these guests
on and you can have these discussions
but then it's your job
to then give the whole picture right if
people are complaining about joe rogan
being like oh you're spraying this
[ __ ] then joe rogan should have two
people
who are from the science community or
ten people from the science community
and be like let's talk about this
together i would love that so we can
have a full picture discussion then you
maybe you'll see eight doctors disagree
with two
and so then the viewer goes okay there's
some validity to what they're saying but
it's not necessarily the whole thing
eighty percent of the community says
they're wrong
right so then you go okay maybe the
science is leaning towards this way and
this is the thing is science is always
changing yeah we're always learning more
and this is why it's so stupid when they
go just believe the science yeah it's
like you it's not a finite it's not a
finite thing you're right but they're
taking that to an extreme you get the
people who are like i'm gonna read
mary's live journal
you know what i mean like that's not
science it's not
it has to be challenged it has to be
reviewed that's a separate issue but the
thing is when you go to these other side
like these extreme people who are like
conspiracy theories and you're like okay
i hear you but here's the mountain of
information read through it they're like
no way yeah no [ __ ] way and then you
go well then what are we doing here
what's the what's happening that's also
like what russell brand has been coming
out with because i think what he's also
doing and it's cool that everything's
coming out in layers right like you have
like the eight doctors versus the two
and then russell brand comes up but do
you see who writes the paychecks to
these eight doctors i agree with that
follow the money
follow the money but this is like when
donald trump had that like jamaican
doctor who was like the vaccine is going
to turn you into a doubt and then all of
a sudden half the country was like yeah
and then you're like well this is
ridiculous right like this is extreme
this is almost borderline like like
magic the gathering
what's going on here right and then
you're like huh and so there's a fine
line but there is you do follow the
money but this is why pharmaceutical
companies and that's what that was that
video is so scary this is why it's crazy
to me it's because why do people believe
that this kind of [ __ ] is just so fringe
and just so crazy that it can't happen
and then and then when we talk about it
right they just want to shut it down and
i'm just like what the [ __ ] this is the
conversations that you need to have
because we need to have everybody in
charge that we rely on to being [ __ ]
keeping the integrity of the medical
community that's the reaction to this
guy is they're all just saying i don't
know he's talking about like that's what
um fda is like oh the fda doesn't know
what they're talking about the fda said
he's not in a position to have known
when he was talking about of course
because they're going to cover up the
track but let's listen to a little bit
more of what he says is visually long
but like
there's there's a little bit more to it
what he's like saying so you don't have
to get an annual shot
he hasn't been formally announced yet
so you don't want to like uh
is it going to be formal you know
i mean it's going to be uh and some of
it's been talked about publicly but it
has been talked about on
like cnn or fox or msnbc or anything
but yeah it'll it'll you'll have to get
an angle i think um what's going to
happen is um it's going to be a gradual
thing school's going to mandate it why
do they need the third one
for the same reason um you or i would
need the firmware
because the
vaccine
it means
um
your ability to fight it wait so the
three will bolster your your system and
then there will be an annual um
eventually an angle just like the flu
shot for the toddlers we're forever
mrna yeah like it only lasts six months
but like also are people like throwing
up in arms about the flu shot when they
invented the flu shot when they were
like hey we're gonna have to take this
well what's where's the part where he's
talking about he's gonna make a ton of
[ __ ] money i think that's the tone
the tone of it because the government
order but like who cares this is like if
they make it mandatory and this is i
don't know like you don't have to pay
for the coveted vaccine i haven't been
had to pay for it you don't have to pay
so it's not like it's not a loss to us
the government's going to pay it's just
well it's tax dollars yeah but this is
why healthcare should be universal yeah
here's why here's a little key thing he
said that a lot of people are kind of
freaking out about is this statement
what do you mean you don't agree with
the process well i mean they um they
don't have all that all the tests aren't
there
so i agree with the thing that is
important to inoculate them
[Music]
yeah that's one of the biggest concerts
yeah that's one of the biggest
controversies right is they're rolling
out the vaccine to uh toddlers and kids
and they're so that's one of robert
malone's arguments he's like it's not
ready yet don't [ __ ] do it it's not
ready i'm against it for kids
yes he's vaccinated but he goes but it's
not ready to roll out for uh the youth
yet and then so did he say did he give
an age like under 10 or like the three
and under it was for tyler's basically
he was like really against that and then
they're like uh they have to do more
testing they're like
and then and i guess it's a conflict of
interest because the guys that want to
roll it out they're gonna make a lot of
money off of it so then that's the whole
issue right now well that's that's the
thing that he's saying is that um like
she's asking him do you really think
it's an emergency for toddlers to like
have this and he's like it doesn't
matter like if it's an um if
everything's under an emergency state
everything gets approved faster so
they're trying to get through that
window
you know it's all right we'll know in 10
years if we grow like a third land i
know i'm trying to get that third lamb
if there's any time for me to turn into
a mutant it's now
so
[Music]
you